you
hello and welcome to part 16 of pattern
recognition for algorithmic trading
where we left off we were drawing
patterns drawing or plotting the
predicted outcomes and color coding them
either green for up or red for down and
then we were also plotting the actual
outcome oh and I forgot to mention on
the last video the some of you might
notice that perfect zero zero comes
across here yet we still have some green
ones underneath zero zero and some red
ones you know continuing already in the
negatives and you might notice that well
actually what's happening is here is the
blue dot and the Reds are below the blue
dot the greens are above the blue dot or
the cyan line rather and so that's
really all this happening there so it's
not it's not percent change a you know
this here is percent change but it's
actually a pattern of percent changes so
it's not quite the same anyway
if that was confusing anybody I just
wanted to mention that I had somebody
asked me about that so anyways so that's
that and now what we want to do is let's
go ahead and plot it so this is actual
outcome but let's plot the average right
so what's the average of all of these
you know quote unquote predictions so
close out of this and the next thing
that we want to do is this shouldn't be
too difficult all we need to do is let's
see print so basically what we're going
to do is do something similar to what we
did with plotting the true outcome array
but it'll be slightly different I
suppose but anyways what we want to do
now is we're going to say well first we
need to predicted outcomes array which
we don't have so scroll all the way to
top two this bad boy and we're going to
add one more and we're going to say
predicted outcomes array so this will be
a red and array of outcomes that are
predicted by this scroll back down all
the way to here ish and and really I
guess we'll just put it right here so
we'll say predicted
outcomes array dot append and what do we
want to Pam well we want to pin
performance array and future points so
we just want to append everything that's
you know it's under this for loop right
so that for loop for each pattern and
then we've already designed defined
future points and so then that social
we're doing that that value right of the
index from performance array so that
value we've got an array now of those so
then what we'll do is we'll come down
here and we'll just put predicted and in
fact let's just highlight this entire
real average outcome array paste and
change this to predicted predicted
average outcome equals red news and then
we're just going to take this you know
predicted outcomes array and paste that
here and then come over and paste that
here as well so now that I'll make an
average of all of the predicted outcomes
subsequently allowing us to come down
here and let's just plot a scatter plot
very similar to the previous one so
apply it scatter and we'll also plot it
for T will plot predicted AVG outcome we
will make I don't know what the heck to
color this color equals let's go give it
blue and will also make the size 25 but
it should be pretty pretty easy to see
the difference so that should be it
let's let's go ahead and close out the
old interpreter and rerun this and see
if we got any errors otherwise we should
get a sexy chart with patterns matching
patterns predicted outcome average
predicted outcome actual outcome so it'd
be very exciting
go please no errors okay the first one
is a pretty boring one so makes total
sense right predicted outcome we only
have one predicted outcome therefore the
average predicted outcome is the same
an actual outcome is up I would still
call this a success predicted up
predicted up actual did up anyway
continuing on I think the next chart
will be a little bit more helpful to us
since it has way more plots on it yes
this one has a lot more for us and so
here we go we've got you know pattern
recognition here's our patterns all of
the predictions and sure enough we did
kind of guesstimate that there were way
more greens than red sure enough the
average prediction is indeed an increase
outcome was actually an increase so far
two successes let's see if we can
actually find an incorrect one so I'll
hit enter for it to continue and then
well look at the next part next after we
I guess we can look at three maybe one
more chart after three it's all positive
okay here's this chart very similar
pattern just cut off you know the last
bit basically and again obviously no
surprise that this was accurate it's
very similar to the previous chart so
yeah I think I'll just cut it here so
now the next real question is okay you
know at this point things are looking ok
so probably a backtest in our future and
but anyway this is that's going to move
this video in the next video we'll be
talking a little bit more about back
testing and then the implementation of
that back testing as always thanks for
watching
thanks for the support of the
subscriptions and until next time